[Music]
controlling flies effectively depends
upon adapting the control methods to fly
habits
these habits will vary with the changing
conditions of weather
temperature and season of the year
therefore the control operator must have
a knowledge of fly biology to apply his
measures to the right place at the right
time
typical of most of the higher insects
the life cycle of the housefly starts
with an egg
from which comes the maggot or larva the
larva
forms a pupa similar to the chrysalis of
a butterfly
and from the pupa emerges the adult fly
the eggs are laid in batches on decaying
organic matter
and a single housefly may lay well over
500 eggs in her lifetime
under normal summertime conditions the
eggs will hatch in 24 hours or less
the larvae feed voraciously and pass
through several growth stages or
instars when full grown they stop
feeding move to a drier part of the
medium and become immobilized
their shape changes and the outer skin
hardens
becoming reddish brown or black this is
the pupil case in which the immature
insect changes into the adult fly
to escape the fly breaks the pupil case
by inflating the talinum a bladder-like
organ on the front of the head
when the fly first emerges the wings are
small and the tilinum extends
prominently forward
but soon the talinum disappears and the
wings expand to full size
the fly is now completely developed and
will not grow any larger
the total period from egg to adult is
eight to twenty days
and there may be fifteen generations a
year
when we talk about domestic flies we
should include several relatives of the
house fly
first there are the blow flies generally
larger than
the house fly and usually shining
metallic blue or green
when blowfly larvae attain full growth
they leave the breeding medium
and may crawl for several yards before
burrowing into the soil to pupate
another domestic fly is the flesh fly
typically with a checkerboard pattern on
the upper side of the abdomen
similar in appearance to the house fly
is the stable fly
the chief difference is in the mouth
parts
the housefly's mouth parts extend
downward and end in a spongy pad
called the labellum unlike the house fly
the stable fly is a blood feeder
and its mouth parts project straight
forward like a bayonet
flies are capable of a considerable
flight range
blowflies ordinarily cover a wider range
than houseflies
but under certain conditions both types
will cover a distance of 10 miles or
more
this means that breeding sites some
distance away may be the source of flies
in the community
the term breeding sites includes almost
any decaying organic material
offering the necessary food and moisture
for larval development
in the fringe area these will include
stock farms
vegetable processing plants
and especially open garbage dumps on the
edge of the community
when a fly population builds up to this
extent
overcrowding may drive them to the
nearby town in search of new breeding
sites
a brief survey of the average community
will reveal many sources of flies
household garbage industrial waste
here maggots are concentrated in the
runoff from a rendering plant
food waste from markets and restaurants
and exposed animal carcasses this
contact of flies with filth and bacteria
makes them a menace to public health
adult flies are unable to eat solid food
they feed only on the liquid part of the
rotting matter
then when they come into our homes to
enjoy a bit of sugar
they first dissolve it by regurgitating
some of the same contaminated fluid into
the sugar bowl
but perhaps even more important are the
familiar fly specks or
germ-laden excreta certainly there can
be no doubt of the ability of flies to
transport filth and disease organisms
removal of the breeding sources is the
most effective measure of all in cutting
down the fly population
that is basic sanitation a primary
objective in community fly control
but the use of insecticides is an
important supplementary measure
and here a knowledge of adult fly habits
is absolutely necessary
flies will not always be found where we
expect them
for instance they usually remain close
to sources of food
but at the approach of a storm house
flies will leave these attractants
and gather at door or window screens in
their attempt to find shelter indoors
during the cool morning hours flies will
rest on walls and fences in the sun
but in the heat of a summer day the same
flies will gather at cool
moist places such as this damp spot in a
dirt road
consideration of these changing daytime
habits of flies is the key to effective
space spraying
at night flies are inactive blowfly is
resting outdoors on wires
low branches or more commonly on foliage
house flies on the other hand normally
rest indoors at night
by daylight the control operator can
recognize the preferred night resting
places by the concentrations of fly
specs
along cracks in walls on overhead
electric wires
or on ceilings and rafters usually
preferring the edges of boards and beams
control experts make use of this
knowledge by examining walls and
ceilings
for indications of preferred night
resting places
these areas are then sprayed with
residual insecticides
for here the flies will remain all night
in contact with the poison
however residual insecticides are also
effective where flies regularly gather
in the daytime
the recent widespread use of chemicals
for fly control
has brought to light another very
important phase of fly biology
early in a fly control program
applications of the insecticide give
encouraging results
but then the flies begin to increase in
numbers
and further use of the insecticide has
little effect
in short the flies have become resistant
to the spray material
all of these facts make it apparent that
fly habits do not conform to a fixed
pattern
that is why the control program cannot
be reduced to a formula
the successful operator must know fly
biology
he must know that the entire life cycle
of the fly
egg to larvae to pupa to adult
takes place in or near the source of
larval food
he should suspect any accumulation
material
as being a possible source of flies a
source that should be eliminated
completely
daytime conditions of weather and
temperature will dictate where
and when to space spray while the
location of fly specs will indicate
nighttime resting places areas where the
application of residual insecticides
will give maximum results
consideration of these phases of fly
biology
means more efficient more complete
control
of domestic flies
you